der energie notfall in deutschland tritt
der in den nächsten monaten ein oder
kommen wir gerade noch davon wie
dramatisch die versorgungslage ist das
zeigt jetzt diese entscheidung der grüne
minister habeck der minister der weg ein
anderer auf erneuerbare energien setzen
will der reaktiviert jetzt
kohlekraftwerke der grüne minister der
wieder auf kohlekraftwerke setzen in
diesen zeiten spielt parteipolitik für
ihn keine rolle mehr dieses erstaunliche
versprechen hat robert habeck am abend
im zdf gegeben
ich versuche mich von dem parteiprogramm
jetzt fernzuhalten und das zu tun was
für die versorgungssicherheit in
deutschland am notwendigen getan werden
muss ja weg von parteiprogramm
verspricht der minister ein minister dem
die sorge anzusehen es vor einem energie
notfall in den nächsten monaten robert
habeck er sagt glasklar im moment sitzt
putin am längeren hebel
es ist so dass es eine art armdrücken
ist wobei putin erst einmal den längeren
arm hatte aber das heißt nicht dass wir
nicht durch kraftanstrengung den
stärkeren arm bekommen können also putin
der den längeren arm gerade hat er seine
kraft ausspielen kann gegen uns weil wir
von seiner energie so wahnsinnig
abhängig sind sagt robert habeck und wie
stark wir putin und seine leute gemacht
haben mit unseren gaszahlungen das zeigt
diese story die geschichte des mächtigen
gazprom chefs und seiner protz villa
bezahlt von deutschen gas milliarden
dass diese riesige trotz villa haben
auch sie bezahlt bezahlt über ihre
gasrechnung
diese riesige trotz seiner nähe von
moskau sie gehört keinem könig keinem
zaren sie gehört dem gazprom chef alexej
miller
finanziert auch von uns deutschen von
unserem geld dem geld für russische
gaslieferungen
alexej miller gazprom-chef seit 2001
teil der russischen elite enger
weggefährte von vladimir putin und mit
den besten kontakten in die deutsche
politik
alexej miller und ex kanzler schröder
immer wieder sind sie bei gemeinsamen
termin auf fotos zu sehen lachen
miteinander scheinen sich bestens zu
verstehen
2005 trat er sogar mit angela merkel am
rande eines länderspiels das team des
inhaftierten kremlkritikers alexej
nawalny macht jetzt diese spektakulären
aufnahmen des geschmacklosen protzbau
veröffentlicht sie in einer doku über
alexej miller und die korruption der
russischen eliten rundum despot putin
mit luft daten weiß das team nach müller
lebt in dieser villa eine riesige
glaskuppel säulen herrschaftliche
terrassen und balkone hierher sprung vom
feinsten die komplette wohnfläche sie
umfasst sage und schreibe
8500 quadratmeter also etwa 85 3
zimmerwohnungen
schwimmbad fitnessraum eisbahn kegelbahn
heimkino biglia zimmer minigolf raum dem
gazprom sheffield es wirklich an nichts
das grundstück selbst unfassbare 62.000
quadratmeter groß neben zahlreichen
gäste häusern befinden sich dort auch
ein pferdestall und eine orthodoxe
kapelle alexej miller mit seiner frau
irina lebt der rose hier wie gott in
frankreich
kein wunder die deutschen bezahlen
weiter fleißig für russisches gas trotz
angriffskrieg und kriegsverbrechen
russisches gas füllt putins kriegskasse
und sichert ihm und seinen oligarchen
ein leben in prunk und überfluss putin
selbst steht gazprom chef miller in
sachen luxus übrigens in nichts nach im
januar enthüllt haben ist ihm dieses
luxuriöse anwesen im zaren stil soll dem
kriegstreiber gehören 1,1 milliarden
euro soll das grundstück gesteckt haben
die russischen eliten und ihren stein
gemeißelte größenwahn möglich auch dank
deutscher gaszahlungen
alexej miller sports villa finanziert
von ihrem geld ihrer gasrechnung
der energie notfall in deutschland tritt
der in den nächsten monaten ein oder
kommt wer gerade vielleicht noch so
davon oder komm rein in einen warmen
winter ja dramatisch die versorgungslage
das zeigt jetzt auch diese entscheidung
der grüne minister habe der minister der
wie kein anderer auf erneuerbare
energien setzen will der reaktiviert
jetzt die kohlekraft wird was für eine
entscheidung in diesen zeiten spielt
parteipolitik für ihn keine rolle mehr
das sagt robert habeck ein versprechen
das er am abend im zdf abgegeben hat und
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit philipp
ita 4 bei unserem bei uns im studio der
chef unseres meinungs- ressorts herzlich
willkommen hier bei uns jetzt also
zurück zur kohle und das ausgerechnet
von den grünen steht da jetzt
umweltschutz gar nicht mehr an erster
stelle und was kann dieser vorschlag
überhaupt bringen in welchen winter
gehen wir da rein ja ich glaube das
zeigt einerseits wie verzweifelt man in
der bundesregierung ist wie sehr man
diesen winter fürchtete man geht
offenbar davon aus dass die russen uns
das gas vielleicht immer weiter ab
drehen werden und jetzt greift man auf
kohle zurück obwohl man natürlich weiß
dass das sämtliche klimabilanzen
zerstört aber ich glaube dass man bei
robert habeck so gut und empathischer
immer kommuniziert doch kritisch
hinschauen muss wenn er sagt
parteitaktik parteiprogramme spielen für
ihn keine rolle wenn das wirklich so
wäre dann würden wir natürlich längst
die lkws verlängert haben und auch wenn
er jetzt sagt na ja das würde bis mitte
ende nächsten jahres dauern das zu
verlängern die brennstäbe zu beschaffen
das hilft uns für diesen winter nicht
deswegen machen wir das nicht dann würde
ich doch gerne sagen was ist denn mit
nächsten winter also ist es bis dahin
friede freude eierkuchen auf dem
europäischen kontinent hat putin sich
bis dahin beruhigt und liefert uns gas
und wir müssen uns keine sorgen machen
nein das ist natürlich nicht der fall
aber offenbar ist sitzt dieser akw hass
so tief bei den grünen dass sie wissen
dass sie dass ihrer basis überhaupt
nicht zumuten können und deswegen lieber
cola als kernkraft wir selber robert
habeck der fordert uns alle jetzt zum
energiesparen auf vor allen dingen
natürlich mit blick auf den herbst
winter wenn dann langsam wieder geheizt
werden müsste zu hause die frage ist ob
das bei freiwilligkeit bleibt oder ob
uns das sparen verordnet wird vielleicht
ja ich werde ja immer skeptisch wenn die
grünen uns jetzt zum sparen aufrufen
denn ehrlich gesagt diese energie spar
agenda das war ja schon lange die agenda
der grünen wenn wir ans tempolimit
denken wenn wir daran denken dass wir
weniger fleisch essen sollen dass wir
weniger in den urlaub fliegen sollen
also dieses energiesparen das war ja
immer das große thema der grünen und
jetzt gibt es natürlich einen guten
grund einen guten anlass um die bürger
dazu aufzufordern und im hintergrund
auch schon damit zu drohen dass man
gesetzlich einschreitet ich würde ja
immer sagen erst wenn der stadt alle
möglichkeiten ausgereizt hat erst dann
kann er überhaupt davon sprechen dass
wir wirklich zum sparen angehalten
werden sollen und solange man bei den
akw sagt nennen das lohnt sich nicht
mehr das wirklich in seinem tempo
abbügelt dass man für deutschland ja
sonst nicht gewohnt ist putin sitzt
derzeit am längeren hebel auch einsatz
von robert habeck einsatz ja auch
wirklich sorge bereitet sitzt putin am
längeren hebel und wie schnell kann dir
wie schnell kann deutschland diese
situation auflösen ja wir drücken putin
diesen längeren hebel ja in die hand da
muss man sagen das waren natürlich nicht
die grünen allein das war allen voran
unsere alt kanzlerin angela merkel die
deutschland wirklich in die absolute
abhängigkeit von putin getrieben hat dir
das jetzt im nachhinein damit begründet
dass man ja irgendwie eine verbindung zu
russland haben wollte man muss sagen
dass es ein historisches versagen dass
europa wegen deutschland schwächer auch
jetzt so schwaches gegenüber russland
dass wir immer drauf schauen müssen dass
der im kreml nicht komplett durchdreht
dass man das dass wir ihn einfach bei
laune halten müssen während er alles
machen kann um uns zu erpressen aber die
grünen tragen natürlich auch eine
mitverantwortung denn der ausstieg aus
den akw
der atomkraft beruht natürlich auf ihrer
jahrelangen kampagne und wir sind jetzt
so schnell ausgestiegen und weigern uns
dass zumindest noch zu verlängern dass
putin natürlich einen sehr langen hebel
hat und der auch immer länger wird je
näher der winter kommt unser bild
meinung chefin pia schaf zu dem
drohenden notstand in sachen
energieversorgung hier in deutschland
und über den grünen minister robert
habeck der versucht das auf seiner linie
alles im griff zu bekommen danke philipp